in this video I will talk about how to
add and remove elements in jQuery if we
need help adding jQuery to your project
check out my getting started with jQuery
video so the append and prepend methods
add new elements as child elements the
target and the after mb4 methods
add new elements as sibling elements so
right now I just have this code up here
and I do have some styling down here and
one thing I do have some styling for a
child element and a sibling element so
it's more obvious what where the child
and sibling elements are so let's add
some jQuery here so first I'm gonna
select the target and then do a pend
okay you can see I appended a div with
the class of child and it just says
append inside and run that and see what
happens remember a pin and prepend add
elements as child elements to the target
so that just means it's going to be
inside the target and it's going to be a
child inside the target and so I'll show
you the same thing with prepend just
gonna copy and paste this and if we will
run that we can see pre pin is inside
the target so now we're gonna do before
and after and as you can see you can
chain these methods together pretty
easily I'm gonna do before but now I'm
gonna do the class as sibling and we'll
put before run there and now it's going
to be before the item and then after
it's pretty much just like that you can
also add more than one element at a time
so if I just go up to the append I'm
going to a comma and I'm gonna add
another element this time I'm going to
add a paragraph element so we appended
this child div and then we appended
another paragraph down here and you can
also append prepend do before and after
too many things at once so for instance
I can select all the paragraph tags
and if I run that you can see the word
Lots was appended to the end of each
paragraph tag and it's in bold and to
remove elements and content there mainly
to jQuery methods we have removed which
removes the selected element and as
child elements and empty which removes
the child elements from the selected
element so let me show you some examples
of that so here I'm selecting the target
and I'm calling the remove method I just
run that the entire target is going to
be gone now we just have the before and
after divs that we added before however
if we move this remove and put it above
when we appended and prepended things
now it's not going to be able to append
prepend things so so now it's not going
to show the before and after because
there's no target to add things before
and after okay let's move that back down
we can also remove all the paragraph
tags so now we just have the child and
sibling divs left and then the other
thing was empty we're gonna go back to
it
selecting the target and I'm gonna run
the empty method so now the target div
is still there but everything inside the
target div is gone I'm going to show you
one final thing with the remove method
we're gonna go back to selecting all the
paragraphs remove and now I can enter a
parameter to filter what's being removed
so if I add a class to this paragraph
tag now I can actually remove it based
on that class so now instead of it
removing all the paragraphs I'm just
going to remove the paragraph that has
the filter class so if I run that you
can see the filter this paragraph was
this div is a target for all sorts of
things and it's not in here anymore okay
well thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good